so und an dieser Stelle sagen wir jetzt
mal guten Morgen Köln
[Musik]
ja lange umstritten war es jetzt gibt es
einen Kompromiss 5 Minuten lang nicht
lauter als 60 Dezibel der ruhezinruf in
Köln ab heute um 13 Uhr 24 Uhr wird er
zum ersten Mal in einer deutschen
Innenstadt zu hören sein ja mit dem
Pilotprojekt für zwei Jahre sei man dem
Wunsch vieler muslimischer Einwohner in
Köln nachgekommen so heißt es von
offizieller Seite die Entscheidung klar
natürlich heftig umstritten vor allem
weil der muizinruf von der
Zentralmoschee in Köln Ehrenfeld kommt
und ja genau die Moschee wird vom
Verband die Tipp gesteuert ja und die
Tipp ist eine Religionsbehörde die dem
türkischen Präsidenten Erdogan
untersteht und immer wieder durch
islamistische und antisemitische
Aussagen aufgefallen ist
sprechen wir darüber mit Dimitri
säubelbild-reporter in Köln Dimitri
guten morgen an Dich ja wie nimmt Köln
denn wie nimmt die Stadt diese diesen
muizin Ruf heute war wie sind die
Reaktionen
die Reaktionen sind gespalten einerseits
gibt es natürlich hier Anwohner bzw
Menschen in Köln die das als Zeichen der
Toleranz sehen andererseitig kritisiert
vor allen Dingen erster Linie als diese
Moschee vor 10 Jahren gebaut wurde hat
man den Anwohnern versprochen eben kein
Problem wird wenn wir kurz mal uns die
Moschee anschauen würden
an dieser Moschee in diesem modierte
waren nie dafür gedacht dass da ein
Medizin von dort aus ähm den Gebetsrufer
aufrufen würde die sind eigentlich
so dass diese muezierung von heute aus
dem Saal aus dem Gebetsteil kommen würde
das ist die erste der erste Kritikpunkt
die jetzt hier von den Anwohnern kommt
der zweite Kritikpunkt ist natürlich wie
eben im Beitrag schon angesprochen es
ist diese Organisation dieser Verband
ist eben den türkischen Staat
unterstellt und damit im erdog und wir
wissen ganz genau welcher Haltung
Erdogan zu vielen Punkten hat die ja
nicht natürlich mit denen wer
die in Deutschland gelebt werden
vertreten werden
Dimitri Köln ist jetzt eine
innerstädtisches Pilotprojekt werden wir
bald in vielen deutschen Innenstädten
regelmäßig Molzen
das ist die Frage die jetzt hier
wahrscheinlich in Köln beantwortet wird
das ist ein Pilotprojekt wie du schon
eben sagtest und das wird jetzt zwei
Jahre dauern allein in Köln ist die
tippe ja nicht die einzige Gemeinde die
sich überlegt jetzt eben diese Mole
zielruf zu starten sondern es gibt
insgesamt 10 Interessenten also zehn
unterschiedlichen Gemeinden die erstmal
sich anschauen würden wie das jetzt bei
diesem funktioniert würde wie würde es
bei der Bevölkerung ankommen und werden
wahrscheinlich auch ihre Anträge stellen
eben auch versuchen dass ihnen Gemeinden
aus deren Moscheen hier in Köln kommen
würde das heißt wir werden gucken
Dimitri seubel aus Köln war heute zum
ersten Mal der moezene Ruf erscheinen
wird danke dir
[Musik]